what you think about games this
I thought it was a bit much
I I was uh I think game is first of all
his album is dope he's got a lot of
great records on that one
um I think um
I think game
with the Eminem Thing feel it just feel
it felt like a nice way to stir up some
[ __ ] for an album coming out but I'm not
sure uh I just feel like I couldn't get
past the
damning voice I know I know game can I
know he can rap better than that you
know so I know I know he he's a he's a
problem you know what I'm saying of
course
as a battle rapper you know what I'm
saying a guy that's in the lyrics I was
waiting for the okay I felt like that
was a little nice little cute intro to
me it was like it's a 10 minute song
right never got out of that though so
it's like if you say he stayed in that
he he stayed in
that Marshall's body for the whole 10
minutes yeah I think if you're gonna
make a 10 minute record like when you
when we gonna get uh game well because
what I'm thinking is he he had another
one of those he had a uh when he was
going against 50 game had a 300 Bars
freestyle exactly so we know that we can
do it you heard that one yeah that [ __ ]
was crazy of course and that was what
happened God damn that [ __ ] was crazy at
the GU not [ __ ] so I mean like I think I
wasn't the craziest fan of of it uh I
think that the album is dope I just
think that like it was probably
probably could have left that one off
yeah man and then I'm sure I mean I'm
not sure he like game is the type of guy
who stands on his own like at all times
so I'm not sure he gives a [ __ ] about
what people think of it or his
relationship with Eminem yeah he stopped
caring about that a long time ago right
right
so yeah I mean so you weren't a fan
of that song no no no no no I think I
think he could have did better yeah but
stack quote here did better
would you say or stack quote could have
did better what are you trying to say
hey statco is a good friend of mine a
good friend of mine too man we all know
are you saying statco Help write the
song yeah I ain't saying nothing man
shout out the game listen I have to say
this because I was in the studio a lot
with the game while I was making this
out he was hey there were no Ghost
Riders in there I'll say that
but stackwell's an amazing writer yeah
former uh aftermath I think about those
Green Lantern mixtape days oh man oh
it's good times man yeah